I built a giant death track on October
7th 2023 Mr Beast posted this video with
a contestant traveling through a series
of obstacles it was a video sponsored by
a mobile game called stumble guys along
with CGI the pivotal moments in the Trap
included obvious
cuts the second trap ends with
contestant Zach diving under a door see
how his leg is here at this point when
it switches to an alternate angle his
leg is
here see the shoes and no bag now here's
a bag and no
shoes the video has more than 150
million
views around half of Mr BEAST's videos
are now game shows
$11,500 their questionable reality is
part of a history that goes back to a
national scandal in 19 1950s it includes
Congressional hearings the dramatic
climax of The probe of fixed and rigged
quiz shows passed aways in Borneo and a
tribe is spoken and a brief era when
cheating on a game show was a federal
crime it's
$100,000 in the 1940s television had
begun advances Across the
Nation and by 1955 a game show called
The $64,000 Question debuted on CBS yeah
$64,000 Question a contestant in an
isolation Booth was asked increasingly
difficult questions the design implied
security and integrity questions were
delivered straight from a bank vault to
the set it was sponsored by Revlon and
was a fabulously successful TV show
topping ratings with 16 million viewers
almost half of all houses that owned TVs
were watching
it it started a quiz show boom these
shows included doto a game where
contestants answered trivia questions to
unlock a connect the dots puzzle the
less said the better in 21 welcome back
to 21 a show where two contestants
appeared in isolation booths each
answered questions for points hoping to
reach 21 it was sponsored by Jal a
supplement that claimed to help with
tired blood tired blood the show and
Trend peaked in 1957 when Time Magazine
put long running quiz champ Charles
voran on the
cover his streak began with the defeat
of Herbert stemle our 29-year-old GI
college student you win $220,000
congratulations Mr VOR voran became a
familyfriendly celebrity TV's own health
restoring antidote to Elvis Presley as
part of the literary voran Clan a family
well-known in New York intellectual
circles after his 12 9,000 streak ended
an amount worth 1.3 million today voran
became the Today Show's cultural
correspondent just 2 months later the
shows were so popular that Time Magazine
was asking are quiz shows rigged there's
all this rigoll about locked vaults one
Insider said but who has the key to the
locked Vault the producer of course soon
everyone would be asking the same
question in summer of 58 dto went blot
the show was cancelled after a
contestant found an answer filled
notebook backstage a slew of shows were
implicated in quiz guilt over the next
few years including 21 Herbert stemple
the 21 contestant who had lost to voran
made claims that 21 was rigged with
producers providing him questions and
thorough stage Direction your time is up
her stle for Five Points which would
give you 21 what Motion Picture won the
Academy Award for
I don't remember I don't
remember the producers claimed stle was
blackmailing them the US House
subcommittee on legislative oversight
began hearings on the quiz
[Music]
shows the report began it is one thing
to arouse and hold the attention of the
viewing public by programs which are
openly and avowedly pure
fiction and should be known as such to
any reasonable person it is quite
another thing however when the airwaves
belonging to the people whose free use
has been licensed by the Federal
Communications Commission are used
deceitfully to exploit for private
profit the interest of the viewing
public stle unloaded details of the
coaching in addition to questions and
answers like that they refused to turn
on the air conditioning in his Booth
thereby causing me to perspire profusely
Char voran arrives to apologize and
attempt to explain to the millions whose
friendship and respect at one vandoran
eventually admitted in testimony he
instructed me how to answer the
questions to pause before certain of the
answers say that was mon on this first
occasion and on several subsequent ones
he gave me a script to memorize and
before the program he took back the
script and rehearsed me in my part but
statement is a ruthful and moving
realization that for his wealth and fame
he paid a bitterly high price the
investigations resulted in voran losing
his job as a Today Show correspondent
and in the cancellation of other quiz
shows though he and others pled guilty
of perjury in earlier testimony he was
freed but more importantly the
communications Act of 1934 was amended
to include prohibited practices in case
of contests of intellectual knowledge
intellectual skill or chance making it
unlawful with intent to deceive the
listening or viewing public with up to a
year of imprisonment the FCC was in
charge and rigging a game show was a
federal crime so what happened well I
was actually a huge Survivor fan and I
found the whole Stacy Stillman Mark
Bernett controversy to be super
interesting after the 1950s a
combination of falling ratings and
public distrust kept game shows lower
profile until a Renaissance the first
person who refuses to eat a bu
loses immunity for their tribe the long
running show Survivor made its debut in
2000 contestants competed in challenges
but crucially elimination occurred via
vote at Tribal Council in 2001 an
original Survivor cast member claimed
the show was rigged essentially Stacy
alleged that in the first season in
order to save a more ratings friendly
contestant you know he's fat but he's
he's good Mark Bernett the executive
producer on the series approached to two
other contestants on the beach and
essentially said to vote for Stacy
instead of that other contestant that
they were planning on voting for years
later attorney George bream started to
wonder did the old quiz show laws apply
in that case I filed a Freedom of
Information Act request from 2000 to
2017 but the lawsuit entered into a
private settlement before any FCC
investigation commenced this followed a
pattern in the 2000s of a weakened quis
show Law the truth is they're actually
not really fighting These reality shows
using that that statute the closest
thing that I found was there was a
planned Fox game show called our little
genius he also happens to be one of the
smartest people in America the planned
2009 show cast kids as quiz competitors
to adults one complaintant to the FCC
said their child had been registered as
a calculus expert but was suddenly
switched to music theory it says a
producer surpassed them note names like
the Hemi Demi semiquaver as the British
name for the 64th note the complainant
ended saying I urge you to conduct an
investigation that investigation was
ultimately abandoned by the FCC because
what the production did was essentially
said hey we're not going to broadcast
this if we don't broadcast this you guys
don't even have jurisdiction and it's
true the FCC only has jurisdiction for
broadcast cable do whatever you want
internet nobody cares you can shoot
something for broadcast but as long as
it doesn't actually air you're not in
[Music]
violation and the timeline of game show
investigations overlaps with a change in
consumption options game shows begin
real was possibly just a window in time
3 2 1 but does it matter that was so I'm
speechless everyone assumes that because
I wrote this paper I am in support of
stronger regulations stronger FCC
enforcement I I really am not uh I think
we're at the point everyone knows that
what's on TV is often fake everyone
knows what's on the Internet is usually
not
[Music]
real Mr Beast has just one FCC license
to help coordinate radio communication
for for his Productions the Mr Beast
team did not respond to our multiple
requests for comment and in 1959 Jarett
Hall and Sominex Sals sworded while van
Doran sweat it stumble guys is currently
number six in action on the App Store I
want to tell you about
stumble hey everybody my name is Phil
Edwards I'm the producer of this episode
if you're anything like me you might be
a little worried now that you have tired
blood tired blood tired blood if you're
a fan of Vox whether you've been
watching us for years or this is your
first video I think that our mission is
still pretty clear that we want to give
you highquality journalism and we want
to keep it free we don't want to put it
behind a pay wall now most newsrooms
they'll make money through either
advertising or subscriptions but there
are a couple big issues with those
models especially for a channel like
ours first advertising goes up and down
with the economy we often only know a
few months out what our Revenue will be
which makes it pretty hard to plan
second we are not in the subscriptions
business Vox is here to help everyone
understand complicated issues not just
the ones who can pay for stuff we think
it's important that everybody be able to
get to it and we can't do it if we have
a pay wall so if those values sound like
your values you can help us reach that
goal help us get to 95,000 gifts by the
end of the year by going to vox.com
now